hello everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report message for this very important
day of the calendar of the year
it is may the 4th so of course may the
4th
be with all of you and my one star wars
comment for the day will be this
the originals stand the test of time
the prequels are getting better with age
great story of accumulation of power and
what corrupt
politicians will do to hang on to power
and the last three sucked worse than
a tauntaun scrotum how was that
no scrotum you can't say scrotum on
youtube i'm not sure
anyway we got a big show for you today
because there's just a lot of craziness
and i'm sensing something kinda good i'm
sensing a little bit of a momentum shift
i mentioned this uh on my locals
community yesterday morning i tried to
set an intention with the community on
monday mornings with the post
and i said i'm feeling something kind of
good here that it seems to me
that more and more people are starting
to wake up starting
to fight back we're seeing more legal
pushback against critical race theory in
schools i'm just censoring there's like
a little brave bravery percolating
so we've got four stories for you plus
i'm going to
show you about a minute long video of
jordan peterson who was on tucker
carlson's
fox nation show uh just in the last
couple days and it's just like a
two-minute sort of
perfect like how can we fix this thing
and perhaps it starts with us kind of
thing
the four stories for today first off uh
target
remember when they burned down target
about a year ago well that very target
in the riots and blm and antifa you know
the diverse and tolerant groups that
they are
they burn down a target well that
target's been rebuilt and they've got
blm messaging on the store now because
the whole freaking thing's a protection
racket but it ain't going to help them
so we're going to show you that
then there's this crazy video out of
california
where a woman was pulled over for using
her cell phone
while driving and just absolutely
verbally berates
the police officer in the worst possible
way and if you haven't seen the video
yet i'm not even going to tip
off perhaps what color she was and
perhaps what race he was
because you know that shouldn't matter
but in this bizarre world
we live in uh unfortunately it does uh
and then we've got a follow-up
video of an officer uh just basically
talking to his camera about
being a good man and and what police
officers are fighting right now because
of mainstream media and public
perception then there was this
cia video a cia recruitment video that
was just released on twitter
that is just the most ridiculously woke
intersectional
nonsensical thing that you're gonna see
today and i know there will be a lot of
those types of things that you're gonna
see today but i can guarantee you good
people
that this will be the most ridiculous
woke thing that you see today
it's got all the buzzwords people and
then finally dc
they kind of let people take off masks
and then they had them put the masks
back
on and it's the hokey pokey and nobody
knows what the hell is going on
so we'll talk all about that and then as
i said we're going to throw to that
jordan peterson video to give you guys a
little a little something to think about
before
tomorrow before we get to all that guys
i want to talk to you about black rifle
coffee
you know black rifle coffee is a
veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee
to people who love america veteran ceo
and founder evan hafer
spent over seven years on the ground
overseas with u.s special forces
and as a cia contractor black rifle
coffee is continually committed to
supporting veteran law enforcement
and first responder causes in our
country and overseas courageous
frontline workers risk their lives every
day to protect
ours inspired by their hard work and
dedication to protecting their
communities
black rifle coffee makes it their
mission to give back to those who serve
however they can
throughout may they are rallying behind
law enforcement officers firefighters
first responders active duty military
and other frontline workers by
spotlighting local heroes through
community nominations donating coffee
to keep the front lines caffeinated and
give back to organizations that support
our nation's heroes
they import the highest quality coffee
beans from all over the world and roast
five days a week at facilities in
manchester tennessee and salt lake city
utah
the team at black rifle coffee is
continually researching and
experimenting with new roasting methods
and coffee origins
purchase at blackriflecoffee.com
reuben and use code ruben at checkout
for 20 off your purchase
including your first coffee club order
that's blackriflecoffee.com
reuben i'm drinking it right now it's
it's hot in l.a today we got about 92.93
out there
so i put it on ice okay so the first
story i want to start with is you may
remember in the in the midst of the
george floyd
riots and and the protests and
everything else when this
happened roughly a year ago right now
one of the
the big videos that went viral was of a
target
being looted and burned down and there
was a pep boys and a dollar tree store
and a whole bunch of stuff
that was being uh you know attacked and
looted and all of this stuff
well that minnesota target store which
was looted
is now displaying a blm mural
that sort of celebrates arson
let's take a look okay so this video is
from
michael tracy and what you can see there
if you look very closely you know you
see some protesters and protests is just
fine and having
your signs is just fine i can't breathe
that's all of course fine and
it's your civic responsibility if you
see an injustice to protest peacefully
and all that
of course the flames the flames that are
around the building that
that seems a bit excessive you've got
the word together there
because they love to juxtapose the
burning down of a building
with you know something that kind of
sounds good right like we're going to
burn this building down but we're doing
it together so it's a good thing that
we're doing
so yes this is at the very target
that was looted last year and i'm sure
you all remember because it happened in
cities across
the united states it happened very close
to my house
in los angeles but let's look at a
little bit of the video of
that very target being looted last year
and then we'll get into
sort of why placating to these people
doesn't really make sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
okay so we obviously could have shown
you plenty more and there were other
stores that were
being burned down uh suffice to say
everyone that you saw in that video was
a criminal i don't i don't think anyone
got charged nobody there brought george
floyd
death like nobody did anything to bring
george floyd back now
ironically i will give credit where
credit is due ironically
the threat of violence may have had
something to do with the george floyd
verdict as we talked about a bunch over
the last couple weeks right if you were
a juror
on that trial it just happened you know
two three weeks ago the verdict
you might be going you know we know that
they
looted stores and burned down stores and
you know they're
threatening violence and maxine waters
is out there threatening violence like
maybe i should just say that derek
chauvin is guilty because i don't want
to get killed and i want to protect my
family that's actually
sort of rational self-interest which is
very scary
but in any event this was a year ago
when all that happened so now let's
throw back to
the image for just a second so that
target was basically destroyed
you know thousands and thousands of
dollars worth of stuff stolen
and target has decided to say oh we will
put these
these murals on the front of our store
including stores
you know buildings burning down as you
can see there and what they're trying to
say is
we'll play along with this thing you
know that we basically
will say oh you guys were sort of just
by destroying
and looting our store and doing criminal
activity you
kind of were trying to do something nice
and maybe you just needed to grab
a couple things over at target over here
now of course the problem is
that this in essence is a protection
racket this is sort of a mafia
protection racket what does the mafia do
the mafia picture like goodfellas
picture any mafia movie whatever your
favorite mafia movie is or picture
sopranos or whatever
they would go to stores and you
basically say to them hey you guys want
protection you want to make sure
that nobody breaks into your store you
want to make sure your stuff doesn't get
lost
right a lot of stuff doesn't fall off a
truck on the way to your store and
everything else
well then you got to pay us well in
essence that sort of protection racket
is being done right here target is
saying hey hey ho ho
you don't want to be burned down again
so we're going to put murals outside
that kind of condone what you did
to us now of course what this really
does is create a self-hostage situation
because the next time
that the riots come and they will come
uh no rioter is gonna be like guys
guys yeah you know i know we're burning
everything down and looting stuff but
target which we did
burn last time and stole all that stuff
nice tv by the way
because uh you know we shouldn't go for
them this time because they did put up a
mural so they're kind of on our side
like that's not
how this thing works if anything they're
putting a bigger target on their back
because they're acquiescing to it
they're actually enabling they're saying
oh
when you do violent things we will then
put your message out there so this is
seriously seriously dangerous stuff
it's completely in line with um well i
guess something that we're going to
reference later when we get to the
jordan peterson video
that we need people to start telling the
truth and
and saying it clearly and and not all
being children with all of this stuff
like whoever's in charge of that target
and that decision that person should be
fired like
you can't burn down buildings you can't
steal stuff in the name of justice
because you that's not how you get
justice right
like can you really think about it
they're going to be burning down the
whole street again
guys guys leave the target alone let's
go to walmart we don't know what they
did
guys let's talk about 1-800 flowers you
know mother's day is coming up and a
mother
is someone who loves you with all her
heart so whether it's your mom
a stepmom or a strong maternal figure
this mother's day celebrate all of the
amazing women in your life with gorgeous
bouquets from 1 800 flowers
dot com right now 1 800 flowers is
offering 24 multi-colored roses plus a
free vase for
34.99 this gorgeous bouquet of two dozen
roses
is an assortment is in an assortment of
bright colors guaranteed to show all of
the moms in your life just how much they
are loved
i can't wait to send a 1-800 flowers
bouquet to my mom and we actually got
one here already just to test it out and
they do look pretty beautiful
and colorful all roses from 1-800
flowers are picked at their peak cared
for every step of the way and shipped
fresh
to ensure lasting beauty picking an
early delivery date ensures you
that your bouquet will arrive to make
mom's day special
24 multi-colored roses plus plus a free
vase for 34.99 is an amazing offer
but prices are going to be going up so
order today don't put it off people
order today from the official florist of
mother's day 1 800 flowers dot com to
order 24 multicolored roses
plus a free vase for 34.99 go to 1 800
flowers dot com
click the radio icon and enter code
reuben that's 1 800 flowers dot com
code reuben and now back to me okay so
we're going to show you two videos here
and i just thought this was really
important to show i i saw the first
video yesterday
uh of this woman absolutely verbally
assaulting this police officer with no
justification in sort of the most over
the top
style assault that you're going to see
and i kind of didn't want to show it
yesterday because i'm trying to figure
out a way how can we address
all of these issues the woke issue the
race issue the policing issue how can we
do all this and not
and not always be talking about it in a
way because the
we keep adding energy to it by always
talking about it but sometimes you've
got to
just show these things to really show
who the good guys are and who the bad
guys are
so i think i've colored this enough this
took place
in san dimas california and this officer
had pulled over this woman because she
was using her cell phone
while driving you tell me if there's a
bad guy in this video and a good guy in
this video and if there's a racist in
this video and a non-racist
in this video we're going to show you
video this is from bill mcghoulin
malugan who got it from a body cam
footage
of the los angeles police officer
take a look good morning which is and
the speed limit is 40
and i was going 38 so why are you
harassing you are correct
i pulled you over because you're a
murderer yes i started to record because
you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving do you have do you have
your driver's license
i it i mistakenly left it at home do you
have a picture of your driver's license
yes i do may have it and can you call
your supervisor please
i already did he's on his way because
you're a murderer okay
and so you're giving me a cell phone
ticket is that why you're harassing me
not harassment i i am enforcing the laws
i have a right to
and record the police when they're
harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i was i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that do you
have
you had a picture of me and made me
think you were gonna murder me okay well
i'm sorry you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer okay
can you zoom in on that for me yeah
thank you and i'm
perfectly legal and i'm a teacher so
there
congratulations zoom in on that phone
now because you're scaring me
they're threatening to kill me and my
son is this your car
yes it is and you're trying to say i
stole my own car because you're jealous
you've got the citation
all you need to do is your signature
he's only citing you for using your cell
phone while you're driving that's it
there you go
sign inside the radio for him being a
mexican racist
what is that name yes it's under
citation man here you go mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that
right
you'll never be white which is what you
really want to be there you go you're
right
have a good day wow lady
wow okay obviously there's a lot there
we're going to go through some
of the quotes just to be clear i don't
care
about what race the officer is i don't
care what race
the woman is but in this
hyper-racialized time that we seem to be
in not because most people care about
this stuff but because the media keeps
pushing about us
it's important that we have to address
that so it does appear that she was
black and apparently he is mexican so
he's latino
again that shouldn't really matter and
he was pulling her over only
for being on her cell phone which she
basically admitted to doing
uh she says that you're harassing me
you're a murderer now
as far as i know that this this police
officer who seems like a pretty mild man
or guy has not murdered anybody
you scared me and made me think you were
gonna murder me
okay you're threatening to kill me and
my son
and then she says that she's a teacher
now if this woman is a teacher and i'm
glad that they blurred her face in this
but if she is a public school teacher
well certainly a public school teacher
if she's a private school teacher as
well that's a different issue
or say a charter school teacher but if
she's a public school teacher the
superintendent
the superintendent of the the super
nintendo as uh
that's what's his name as ralph wiggum
would say uh
has to bring this teacher in the
principal of the school has to bring
this teacher in
and find out what it is she's been
teaching her students because clearly
someone who's saying
that sort of over-the-top crazy stuff
that is
obviously like deeply
embedded in her ethos and there is no
doubt she is leaking that
awful attitude and that deeply racist
actual actually racist way of looking at
the world into
her classroom so somebody needs to look
at that i'm glad that in
that she was blurred so that there isn't
a mob going after her right we don't
need the online mob going after her even
the real-life mob but somebody knows who
she is and
and that should be looked into uh and
then of course at the end when she
really goes off here
here you go you you mexican racist
you're not white like
he didn't say anything racist she's the
racist there is a racist in this picture
lady but it's you you're the racist now
of course
the workstars won't know what to do with
this because can a black person be
racist to a latino person and where does
that fit
in the intersectional calculator and
everything else but any man i thought it
was worth showing you this because
police officers are basically under
assault right now
that doesn't mean every single one of
them is perfect and by the way not every
single accountant is perfect not every
single clown is perfect not every single
youtube talk show host
is perfect most of them but not every
single one of them but this endless
assault
where people feel they can do that sort
of thing and then spew
racist nonsense at these officers is
just crazy and by the way we know
we know this is actually affecting our
police officers there have been
mass early retirements across the nation
because people
that are getting close to retirement or
maybe we're sticking around for another
year or two doing desk jobs or whatever
they're just like who wants this
nonsense who wants to deal with this
who wants to get into a fracas and then
not be backed up by their own department
or by the the mayor
or by the media or anything else so
police officers are really feeling it
and then of course we know when you
defund the police
and you don't back your police we get
more crime we get more murder all of the
stuff that you guys well know about
uh well then i want to follow this up
with a video from tiktok
this is a police officer by the name of
kelvin dingle
and he took a video in his car and and
it really is just
just the sort of perfect expression of
the frustration
that these good decent men and women are
dealing with on a day-to-day basis
i wake up every morning
and kiss my family goodbye knowing that
there's a possibility
i won't come home i am tired of every
time i wake up
in the morning there's someone else
polarizing the fact
that maybe law enforcement is just not a
good thing
all of us are not bad i am not as they
are most of us are not there are bad
people
in every career i'm so goddamned
[Music]
tired
[Music]
god bless that man if anyone is in touch
with officer kelvin dingle i'd be happy
to have him on the show if he wants to
talk if there's any kind of gofundme
that i can support or promote i'm happy
to do that as well you guys know the
story of the
the other officer who made the the funny
really funny video
mocking lebron james right because
lebron james went off on the officer
who saved the girl's life who was about
to be stabbed by another girl
so an officer what was that guy's name
can we can we pull up his name
who really uh just did a really funny
video making fun of
of lebron james he then got suspended so
a gofundme went up i donate some money i
promoted it if he wants to talk i'd be
happy to talk to him like i want to help
these guys they don't deserve
the attacks that they are under and we
all know
we all know this to be true that if
there was something really bad
happening to us or someone we love we'd
want the police to be there and they're
just an easy punching bag right now
by the way the name of the officer who
did the video on lebron thank you
was uh idaho deputy marshal nate
sylvester it's a really great video
if you haven't seen it it's just funny
like beyond anything else it's just
funny like mocking the ridiculousness
of lebron anyway i just i know a lot of
a lot of boys in blue and women in blue
i know you watch this show and i try to
always say hi to you guys when i see you
on the street and
often i hear that a lot of you guys dig
what i'm doing
we stand with you most of america stands
with you
and as officer dingle said right there
it's like are there a couple bad apples
of course there are but there are in
every
every career but these are good people
who are trying to do something good
by by and large and they deserve our
support
all right let's let's shift a little bit
although this is a it's really just a
slight shift here
the cia put out a recruitment video
yesterday
on twitter now i say this is a slight
shift because we're going from talking
about policing
which is a governmental institution to
the cia which is one of our most
cherished government institutions right
we need intelligence
and these are institutions that we would
hope um
wouldn't be affected by the whims of
day-to-day politicians or what the
cultural norms are of the day we would
hope that these
institutions would last to always do
what is right for the country that they
would not be infected
by whatever just happens to be happening
right now and now and we know that the
dominant cultural force right now
is wokeness and according to this video
if you watch it it's about two minutes
long and trust me you're going to want
to
if you got a pen and paper with you
people i'm going to do it with you
you're going to want to write down some
of these quotes because this is some
really banana stuff so this is
a cia recruitment video and you tell me
you tell me is are they hiring the best
and the brightest based on
qualifications
to to form an organization that can do
the best to protect america
or maybe there's something else going on
you tell me
when i was 17 i quoted zora neale
hurston's how it feels to be colored me
in my college application essay
the line that spoke to me stated simply
i am not tragically
colored there is no sorrow dammed up in
my soul nor lurking behind my eyes
i do not mind at all at 17 i had no idea
what life would bring but sora's
sentiment articulated so beautifully how
i felt as a daughter of immigrants then
and now nothing about me was or is
tragic i am perfectly made
i can wax eloquent on complex legal
issues in english
while also belting guayaquil de
misamores in spanish
i can change a diaper with one hand and
console a crying toddler with the other
i'm a woman of color i am a mom i am a
cisgender millennial who's been
diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder
i am intersectional but my existence is
not a box checking exercise
i am a walking declaration a woman whose
inflection does not rise
at the end of her sentences suggesting
that a question has been asked
i did not sneak into cia my employment
was not
and is not the result of a fluke or
slipped through the cracks
i earned my way in and i earned my way
up the ranks of this organization
i am educated qualified and competent
and sometimes i struggle
i struggle feeling like i could do more
be more to my two sons
and i struggle leaving the office when i
feel there's so much more to do
i used to struggle with imposter
syndrome but at 36
i refuse to internalize misguided
patriarchal ideas of what a woman can or
should be i am tired of feeling like i'm
supposed to apologize
for the space i occupy rather than
intoxicate people with my effort
my brilliance i am proud of me full stop
my parents left everything they knew and
loved to expose me to opportunities they
never had
because of them i stand here today a
proud first generation
latina and officer at cia i am
unapologetically
me i want you to be unapologetically you
whoever you are know your worth command
your space
mija you're worth it
boy oh boy all right i hope you wrote
some stuff down because i wrote some
stuff down here
um because it actually starts off okay
you know she's a colored person that's
fine she's daughter of immigrants that's
fine
she's multilingual and she's a mom
that's fine actually multilingual
especially in the cia could be really
great
you know if we're sending you to the
middle east let's say and you speak
arabic that would be pretty fantastic
then it sort of devolves into like the
crazy
woke intersectional nonsense including
the word intersectional
she says she's a cisgendered millennial
that just means
she's a young person who's in the body
that they're supposed to be in a
cisgendered millennial
she suffers from general anxiety
disorder
i don't know why she'd be bringing that
up in this video i mean that's just fine
and i hope
that she's dealt with it now i would
imagine that being in the cia is a
rather stressful job and having people
that have psychological conditions like
generalized anxiety disorder maybe
that's a problem but
i'm going to guess that they looked at
her and she had to go through whatever
the proper evaluations were and she
she passed whatever tests there are now
that question is are the tests
constantly being lowered in the name of
equity i don't know that specifically
then she says that she's intersectional
so she's got all of her oppressions and
she can match them up against other
people's oppressions and figure out
where she fits on the intersectional
scale and then she used to struggle with
imposter syndrome
that seems like a problem to me if
you're going to be in the cia
double agents triple agents quadruple
agents and now you've added in someone
with imposter syndrome i don't know what
imposter syndrome is
i have no idea i you think you're an
imposter it doesn't even matter
but the fact that they would put that in
the video okay she's got generalized
anxiety disorder she's intersectional
can we get somebody else that's not
enough anyway is there anyone that has
struggled with being an imposter in
their life that we can put in this video
let's get that girl
so she was also she struggled with
impostor
syndrome and she also doesn't want to
uh be under the foot of those misguided
patriarchal
ideas and then of course she references
her parents who came here to make a
better life for themselves
but in essence what she's really saying
is that why did they come here because
obviously this place is so messed up
with all those patriarchal ideas so
so nothing that the woksters or the
intersectionalists
say really makes any sense but but
putting all that aside and i don't want
to make this about that girl i don't
even
know her name maybe they said at the
beginning i'm not even sure actually it
doesn't even matter actually
the bigger issue is what wokeness is
doing to our institutions now again
i hope that girl's perfectly qualified i
hope she's dealt with her generalized
anxiety disorder i hope she's dealing
with the imposter syndrome i mean just
the fact that
is this is like the like a leslie
nielsen comedy it really is like
who who's working at the cia now well
she has impostor syndrome like it sounds
like a chevy chase movie
really does but okay fine the point is
that once you start making
all of those things important right and
what you know she also says at the end
and i want to be me and i want you to be
you well it's like boy
all the things that make you you don't
they sound like things that that really
just make you like everybody else
because everybody else is intersectional
and everybody else
is black or white or gay or like it's
all
it ain't good but as my friend pete
begosian says and i i talk about this
all the time
once in an organization you allow
wokeness and you allow diversity
inclusion you say
okay we're going to judge on all of this
stuff well then the mission whatever the
mission
is of your organization is going to
suffer because any good organization
my organization here i don't hire based
on the color of skin or do either one of
you have impostor syndrome
o'connor wait connor pointed at michael
all right so well
you and you pointed it like all right
i've got two impostors here potentially
but i didn't even know that before this
began and had i known i probably if
someone put on a resume like really if
you're at a company
and you're looking you're like okay went
to college great was in
you know spanish okay basketball
intramurals
uh suffers from imposter syndrome like
you're probably not going to get the job
and again i'm not making fun of people
with imposter syndrome
i well i guess i am a little bit but not
like really really you know
and if i am i blame it on the imposter
um but the point is you guys
that once you're in an organization you
want to hire the best people to do the
best work and
and that always is how you make people
better regardless of their skin color
and regardless of their sexuality and
their imposter syndrome and everything
else
so once you bring this stuff in you
start degrading the very core
purpose of these organizations and that
now goes for the cia
that goes for you know if you're a
programmer and you want to work at
twitter or facebook it goes for all of
our
educational institutions and that's this
is in essence why we're seeing
everything crumble
and by the way who would really enjoy
that video you know who probably really
enjoyed that video
i'm guessing uh somebody in china that
probably would love to see
the united states collapse they're
probably digging that video like look
how unserious
the united states has become that they
put out recruitment videos where people
are talking about generalized anxiety
disorder
impostor syndrome intersectionality the
patriarchy it's like
buzz word nonsense like boys we don't
have to fire a
shot okay don't worry guys we don't have
to drop the bomb on the u.s
they're going to do it to themselves
like that's kind of where we're at at
the moment it is
it is not what a serious country would
would do and i just want to say
that this has no uh reflection of how i
feel about what the core mission of the
cia is nor
the probably 90 something percent of
people who work there who are good
decent people who just want to serve
their country
much like i just described with the
police officers in the previous segment
but these ideas are in there and until
good people stand up against these ideas
we are in a lot of trouble so that is a
perfect segue to the final story that i
want to cover this is this isn't even a
story
in a traditional sense um you know what
let's let's skip the let's skip the
dc thing we'll do it another day if we
want long story short in dc
muriel bowser who's the mayor there they
they opened up for a day
you didn't have to wear masks then they
closed it like it's all just nonsense
you guys get it but i think
i think a better finish to today and a
better segue from the two stories that
we just did would be this jordan
peterson video so jordan peterson
uh you guys know how i feel about jordan
uh he was on tucker carlson's
fox nation show and we're gonna show you
about about a minute and a half clip
here
where he's talking about the truth and
why you have to tell
the truth you know you you you make your
decisions in life and i decided when i
was very
young i'm in my mid-20s that i was going
to say what i believed and see what
happened
i talked to you earlier in the talk
about adventure you know about
the adventure of truth and i don't
think i'm happy about what has happened
and i certainly have dragged my family
through their fair share of
well both hell and and also
incomprehensible opportunity
it's expanded our lives in both
directions to a tremendous degree
but it's certainly been an adventure
it's not been dull
and i don't believe that it i don't
believe that it was a mistake
whatever happens as a consequence of
telling the truth is the best thing that
can
happen it doesn't really matter how it
looks to you at the moment or maybe even
across the years
because you have to it's it's a it's a
it's an article of faith in some sense
do you believe that reality is better
constituted as a consequence of truth or
falsity
if you believe that reality is best
constituted
as a consequence of truth then you have
a responsibility to speak the truth
and you can't assess the consequences
and say well that was a mistake because
part of the decision that reality is
best constituted
as a consequence of the truth is the
decision that no matter what happens
is the best if it's a consequence of
telling the truth
and so that's what i conclude it's like
this is what happened because i said
what i had to say
as clearly as i could say it and that's
as good as it could be
now whether or not that's good well it's
good compared to all possible
alternatives
all possible realistic alternatives
that's an article of faith as far as i'm
concerned you know our culture is
predicated on the idea
that truth in speech is of divine
significance it's the fundamental
presupposition of our culture
well if you believe that then you act it
out
and you take the consequences
you're going to take the consequences
one way or another you know
so you want the truth on your side
or do you want to hide behind falsehoods
you want the truth on your side or do
you want to hide behind falsehoods that
is the truest thing
that you're going to see today and if
you want just that
clip since you're watching this on
youtube i did tweet out just that clip
itself this morning which actually
jordan retweeted and commented on but i
want to read you a couple of the quotes
there because it's
it's powerful stuff it's something that
i'm trying desperately to do with this
show but not only with this show with my
life
and i do believe the more that you say
the truth the more that you say here i
am i am here i will not take this
bs anymore i will stand for what i
believe and i will say clearly what i
believe
the more that you do that the more
goodness that you put in the world and
as jordan says
it doesn't mean everything's going to be
good but it will be the best of all
alternatives because it will by
definition be better than what
reality you would create by putting a
lie out in the world and i think
we're in a time where everyone's just
putting out lies
everyone is putting out lies all the
time our institutional leader putting
out lies our media elite
are putting out lies and no one's saying
i this is it
i've drawn the line i'm going to stand
here and tell the truth and i wonder
i really do wonder if all of us really
started doing it
if we all did it for a week imagine if
every single person watching this show
let's say on average we get about 150
000 views on one of these shows
if 000 people just started for one week
to really tell the truth not skirt the
truth not
not [ __ ] not lie in whatever
capacity that is it doesn't mean you
have to run around
screaming true things all the time but
if in your day-to-day life you acted in
a true way
maybe we could start resetting this
stuff maybe that could
stop us uh on this on this descent to
marxist hell that we seem like we're on
but just uh one specific quote that i
want to read whatever
happens as the consequence of telling
the truth is the best
thing that can happen that seems right
to me
and as jordan says that is an act of
faith
and you may remember about two three
years ago when i was on tour with jordan
peterson he did
three or four shows with sam harris
where they basically were debating the
nature of reality
sam from an atheist perspective and
jordan from the perspective of
of a believer of someone that has some
degree of faith and and i watched
the videos that went up and and it was
very obvious to me that jordan was
saying something that was truer and more
meaningful and
and certainly more broadly impactful
than what i would say is sort of
the very myopic uh atheist perspective
that's my personal take on it and i
wrote a bit about how that affected me
and don't burn this book
um but he goes on to say that that is an
act of faith
that just believing that if you tell the
truth
that that is better than a lie believing
that that's the leap
that's the leap right there that is
freaking powerful stuff
that is powerful stuff and i promise you
i'm going to keep trying to do it and i
hope you will keep trying to do it with
me
it's good compared to all the possible
alternatives meaning no matter what
great lie you pull
it can't be better it can't be better
than just simply stating what the truth
is
so i think that's our job for those of
us that want to fix this thing
that is our job to keep pushing for that
and it doesn't mean you'll you'll do it
perfectly
all the time you know sometimes we lie
about like little nonsensical things
somebody will be like
oh did you see that that new show on
netflix and like yeah i did oh yeah it
was great it was great and it's like
we were like wait a minute why did i lie
why didn't i just no i actually didn't
see it like we've all done like little
things like that but what if we
all do our best to not do that and
certainly not lie about the big things
certainly if someone
asks you your true opinion about
something to to not
hide or or disguise the truth or
outright lie just because it's easy and
it's expedient
i think maybe that's the path out of
this thing i really do
the path is not because a politician is
going to save us it is not
and it isn't because there's some
magical force that's going to save us we
might be the magical force
all together by doing what's right
that's that's the best estimation i got
in this thing
um i posted the video as well in in our
locals community and we've got a lot of
people going back and forth on that so
i'd love to continue that conversation
so if you want to join us for that do
check out reubenreport.locals.com
uh part two of my interview with nikki
haley the former south carolina
governor and u.s ambassador to the un
and possible
2024 republican presidential nominee
we'll see i do ask her about that
part two is up right now on youtube full
episode up ad free at local
reubenport.locals.com and
as they say may the fourth
be with you